[Musique]
hong kong apport riches aux frontières
de demande et tout autour des baraques
entassés des bidonvilles brio une
capitale ultra moderne avec des
buildings et une route qui dessine son
tracé futuriste sous un bidonville
c'est là un phénomène général
international new york ou moscou
les bidonvilles n'épargne aucune
capitale paris pas plus que les autres
et voici un document tourné en toute
objectivité malgré les difficultés qu'on
peut imaginer sur cette plaie des
grandes cités à nanterre ou à la
courneuve les bidonvilles ressemblent à
ceux de toutes les latitudes ils se
ressemblent tous quelques planches mal
jointes des toits fait de n'importe quoi
sur un terrain vague des hommes venus en
masse travailler dans la région
parisienne ont fait naître ces sites est
misérable africains du nord portugais
espagnols et aussi des français
si le jt précaire du moins il est bon
marché et dans ce souci d'économie on
peut trouver une des raisons d'être du
bidonville une seule fontaine pour toute
la triste agglomération c'est le rendez
vous des enfants
la corvée d'eau remplace souvent l'école
on vit entre soir des commerçants ici
leur inventaire à la mesure et à l'image
de l'habitat
[Musique]
et l'heure du marché ressemble à toutes
les heures de marché mais on est dans un
autre univers non l'univers de la misère
car la plupart de ces hommes ont un
emploi mais un univers de hasard de
passage insoupçonnable et souvent
insoupçonnées
[Musique]
pas de service de nettoyage les chiens
s'en occupe
mais rien est redoutable comme l'hiver
lorsqu'il cern ces constructions
chancelante
il n'y a guère que le poil de femmes de
l'épicerie buvette qui prodigue quelques
chaleurs chaleur humaine aussi car c'est
là qu'on retrouve d'autres en parlant la
même langue
à l'heure de la détente
ailleurs il faut accumuler les vêtements
pour lutter contre ce froid que n'arrive
pas à combattre la flamme du foyer ainsi
vivent dans les conditions de la misère
des centaines de familles aux portes de
la grande vie insouciants des enfants
meubles ce décor sans espoir de leur jeu
sans fin
on
et
comment résoudre le problème
continuellement méthodiquement les
constructions nouvelles grignote les
bidonvilles
[Musique]
les bulldozer adapte ici et là l'une de
ces sites et de planches de partage et
de tôles pour laisser la place à des
habitations digne de ce nom
ici se levait un bidonville
la construction s'efforce de faire face
aux flux des nouveaux venus mais il ne
suffit pas de remplacer un bidonville
s'il doit en être un autre un peu plus
loin
[Musique]